lord how are the increase that trouble
me many are they that rise up against me
many they be which say of my soul there is no help
for him in god but thou o lord at a shield for me
my glory and the lifter up of my head i cried
unto the lord with my voice and he heard me out
of his holy hill i laid me down and slept i awake
for the lord sustained me i will not be afraid of
ten thousands of people that have set themselves
against me round about arise o lord save me o my
god for thou hast smitten all my enemies upon the
cheekbone thou has broken the teeth of the ungodly
salvation belongeth unto the lord thy blessing
is upon thy people god is good and all the time
let's try that again god is good and all the
time psalm 100 verse 5 for the lord is good
his mercy is everlasting and his truth endureth
to all generations as long as there has been god
there has been truth error came in some time
later and it will pass away as long as god exists
there will be truth and so i say again god is
good and all the time when god punishes you
why do you hesitate when god punishes us when
he blesses us when he answers our prayers
when he says no he cannot help but be
good that's his nature psalm 145 verse 17
the lord is righteous in all his ways and holy in
all his works meaning god cannot do anything wrong
are you with me no matter how we get angry
with him jesus said in john 15 26 or 2025
they hated me without a cause no one
has ever had an intelligent reason
to be angry with god i've been angry sometimes and
i've had to apologize for my momentary insanity
there is no good reason to be angry with god i
love god how many of you love god can i say i have
he's such a nice person and i like to say i like
god you know everyone says i love him but i like
him not every person you love you like but like
some relatives but and i like god are you with me
there's some relatives you don't mind me to never
visit but you love them but you don't like them
particularly but i like god let me say this about
god in all my life long or short as it has been
god has never done me anything wrong never
every blessing has come from god and i thank him
every hardship i brought on myself by my supremely
stupid choices and decisions and so i publicly
say god is innocent of any wrongdoing in
my life and i'm sure you can say the same
how was your day he was blessed well then
god was with you the family are born again
and bayport baytown porte yes i'll get it straight
before i die baytown laporte wherever you are
and i hope to see you what camera should i
look into to look right at them which one
oh right up there oh hi bay daytown report nice to
see you god bless you look nice i see you by faith
we shall meet please don't worry thanks for
loving christ and for loving the truth is there
anyone present tonight for the very first time and
you're not a seventh-day adventist miss your help
first time you're not a seventh-day adventist
nobody if there's someone hiding just do that
anybody anybody okay if you're at baytown or
uh la porte or you had born again and your
guest thank you very much and may god and i
really mean it place a heavy heavy blessing
on your life our subject for this evening
higher than the highest what did i say
higher than the highest before i get into that
remember always i appeal to you respectfully
preserve reverence in your mind in your
environment those of you online at your homes
god is holy it does not change because you're
on zoom or youtube or whatever god is always
holy he's an up and down god he's always holy
so preserve reference where you are favor number
two while i'm speaking pray for me and say lord
put your words in that man's mouth jeremiah
chapter 1 verse 9 then the lord put forth his hand
and touched my mouth and the lord said unto
me behold i have put my words in thy mouth and
jesus said the words that i speak unto you they
are spirit and they are life he did not say that
about my words my words have no value
favor number three as you listen think
i have not done a survey or any
research project but i believe
if more people would think they would
not attend the churches they attended
they would not date the people they date say amen
it would not marry some of the people
they married if they had stopped to think
when you understand what
alcohol does to the system what
uh what's the thing in cigarettes nicotine does to
the system what drugs do the system you don't take
we must learn to think and so
the bible says come now let us
reason together as i said last night god is a
reasonable god i like that about him let's pray
dear god in heaven we come before you because we
have nowhere else to go to get help help that lad
that benefits us now and in the years to come
we ask immediately father if we sinned forgive
us dear god cleanse us wash us that we may be
acceptable in your sight through jesus christ
we present ourselves to you nowaday god as we bow
in your presence receive us father as i speak as
your servant speak through me dear god help me to
literally see myself as an instrument in your hand
i offer no resistance tell me what to say when to
say it and how to say it remember anyone listening
to god who may be sick with the coronavirus in
the name of jesus who loves us who died for us
heal that person father because the bible says of
you in psalm 103 verse 3 who forgiveth all thine
iniquities who healeth all thy diseases and father
you said to us through moses in exodus 15 26 i am
the lord that healeth thee remove the affliction
they got just to ease suffering do that decade
now let this message glorify your name and
bless everyone listening i pray if their
children watching online be with them father
jesus was a child and he loved the scriptures
so bless the little children in a very special
way i pray in jesus name amen what's our subject
higher than the highest let's go to
genesis 1. we read verse 26 of genesis 1.
i read from the king james version of the bible
it's 7 33 i let you out by 8 15 possibly before
elohim said we should cut our sermons in half and
we do much more good i have not yet learned that
lesson but i'm working on it what book did i say
what chapter reading for what verse and god said
let us make man in our image after our
likeness stop look at that passage again
let us make man in our image
after our likeness god said that
then we need to understand something
about god in order to appreciate
his likeness and his image are you following me
if someone tried to make me in the image of a
crocodile and i know what a crocodile looks like
i will put up a fight are you following me all
right so we need to understand what god is like
go with me to john chapter 4 we'll read verse 24.
we just read and god said let us make man in
our image let's find out something about god
john chapter 4 we read verse 24. now this
is the son of god speaking and he and the
father were one they are one jesus said
he that seeth me have seen the father
so jesus knows what he's saying because he
existed with the father before he came in
human form listen to what jesus says to you right
now read with me john 4 24 god is a spirit stop
now listen to genesis 1 26 and god
said let us make man in our image
what image is there spiritual
listen to me carefully we were made primarily to
live up to a spiritual standard not a secular one
we're we're in uh texas so this is
the dallas cowboy territory even
though dallas is some distance away
but this is texas the cowboys want
a good quarterback they don't go to
the high schools are you following me
that level is too low are you with me they
look for another pro somewhere someone who
was performed at the very highest level so they
tried to steal a quarterback from the new york
jets or from whomever new orleans saints or
from the new england patriots they want the
very best and they're always trading and giving
up why they don't trade for high school players
because they want the best now listen again and
god said let us make man in the image of an angel
why not
come on why not what's your subject you took
too long what's your subject now listen to me
and god said let us make man in the image of an
angel and you said no and my question is why not
not high enough one way to show love for
your children is to set high standards
uh one person said yes come on i'm going to uh
born again i'm not coming back to this church
one way to show love for your
children is to set high standards
your child comes home with a report card every
grade is an f and a g you'll move to another town
because you're embarrassed when your
child has always you put on your bumper
uh parent of an honest student
now and god said let us make man tell me in our
image after our likeness so that the image of god
reflected in us must be first
and foremost a spiritual
keep this in mind let's go now to ecclesiastes 12.
is 737 our subject higher than the highest
there's some people who hate high standards
you really do you see it in the way they dress
they don't like high standards they like high
hems but not high standards what book did i say
i can't hear you what did you say yeah what
chapter ah come on you're sharp chapter 12
reading for what verse 13 13. my trinidadian
brother use sharp do we have ecclesiastes 12 13
as usual nobody answered the preacher all right
i feel so lonely okay let's pray father as i
continue please lord tighten your grip on my mind
in jesus name i pray amen listen to the wisest
man whoever lived he didn't behave like that all
the time but he was the wisest man who ever lived
let us hear the conclusion of the whole matter
in other words solomon is writing towards the
end of his life he looks back over his life
all his partying all his drinking all his
womanizing everyone's a thousand wives of women
all of that he looks at and he summarizes let us
hear the conclusion of the whole matter what's
life all about come on tell me fear god come on
and keep his commandments for this is the whole
duty of man you may ask what's the connection
between that and genesis 1 26 i'll show you
the whole duty of man is to fear god and keep
his commandments but let us learn something
about the commandments of god go to romans
chapter 7 our subject higher than the highest
romans 7. wrote the book of romans yes paul
the second greatest teacher of the bible was paul
who was the greatest jesus yes no one can teach
scripture like jesus no one do you have romans
chapter 7 verse 4 not 4 sorry verse 14 read with
me if you have my version for we know that the
law is spiritual but i am carnal soul than the
same in other words we are the very by nature
by birth we are the very opposite of the law
i seem to have lost some of you let me say it
again listen to the verse read it microscopically
for we know that the law is spiritual keep reading
but i am carnal that's paul before his conversion
sold on the sin so we are by nature carnal
before we're born again the law is the precise
opposite it is spiritual now when we're
born again in what direction do we move
from carnal come on to
spiritual not carnal to secular
you know that was god's standard
when he said let us make man
in our image because god
never changes his standards
for we know that the law is spiritual but i am
carnal soul and the sin now since i am carnal
and the law is spiritual let me represent it
this way this is paul he's carnal this is the law
spiritual the two can't mix you are they can't
get along what has to happen for them to get along
one has to change either the law becomes
come on come on either the law becomes
carnal or the carnal person becomes spiritual
you can't mix the two many of us try
but you cannot mix the two there's
no vegetarian form of the world
are you with me go to john chapter three quickly
john three our subject higher than the highest
john chapter three we thank god for easing up
lorraine that his people can come to his houses
of worship but the earth needs to rain so we
thank him for that as well it reminds us of
the latter rain and the early reign jesus says
sends his reign upon the just and the unjust
what book did i say john what chapter 3 what
verse 6 read it for me that which is born of the
is and that which is born of the spirit
is now stop okay let's look at that verse
microscopically what you understand by
that which is born of the flesh is flesh
okay but listen okay well let's change the word
that which is carnal is carnal what does that mean
okay let's go to the other side that which is
born of the spirit is spirit what does that mean
okay catch this that which is born of the flesh is
flesh means that's all it is flesh that which is
born of the spirit now you tell me that's all it
is come on spirit which means there is no uh-huh
in the spirit ah i've lost you or you've lost
me there is no flesh in the spirit i'll finish
my remarks there is no in the flesh now
why do i say that go back to romans 7.
a lot of us like to mix up the
world with our christian experience
we can't do that you can't do that well you
can but that does not make you a child of god
and you're also hypocritical to the
world because you're not fully the
world or fully god so hypocritical to both
sides romans 7 verse 18 do you have that
what does that say for i know that in me that
is in my flesh dwelleth no good thing now there
is nothing good about the flesh therefore there
cannot be one molecule of the flesh in the spirit
now there's nothing evil
about the spirit it's all good
therefore there can be nothing
of the spirit in the flesh
you either belong to god or
you don't but he loves you
a lot of us we are mentally troubled because
we're not fully gods we're not fully his
and when we're in this kind of uncertain state
it produces mental conflict but when you make
up your mind i am all for god i'm all for the
world it brings peace yes all for the world you
have some peace because your mind is made up but
jesus died that we might make up our minds to be
all for god and so genesis 1 26 and god said let
us make man in our image john chapter 4 verse 24
god is a spirit so that image was spiritual we
are first and foremost spiritual beings in a body
i said that the whole duty of man
is the law we're not i didn't say it
solomon said it but we found
out the law is spiritual
did you read that in romans 7 4 for we know
that now which means then listen to me carefully
if the whole duty of man is to keep god's law
and the law is spiritual what's the whole
duty of man to be spiritual and living yes
does that deny the flesh not at all does
that deny that part of your life that
is three-dimensional not at all it simply means
that the the the center of your being is spiritual
i preached a sermon many years ago called i'll
have a diet pepsi and if i remember the sermon you
know there's the the straight pepsi with all the
stuff that is the diet pepsi which is just as bad
some people say give me a diet pepsi
you see it's not as bad give me that
we want a diet world are you following me
give me the diet world not the one with
the caffeine give me the diet world but there's
no such thing you either spiritual or a carnal
no having said that let's see how we should walk
we're just building let's see how we should walk
go back to romans chapter 8 let's read verse
14. now go to galatians 5 let's read verse
25 galatians 5 then we'll come to romans where's
my lovely sister who recited the books yesterday
oh god bless her god bless her what's the
name margie system arty god's daughter
do you have romans five okay i said i
thought they said you were outside okay
okay okay all right galatians 5 verse 25 read
that first form what does this say if we let us
yes now when you read if we live in the spirit it
means if we have gotten life through the spirit
then live in the spirit the bible says as he has
received the lord jesus come on so walking in
if we have received spiritual life by
the spirit and it is the spirit that
brings about that through the word then the
bible says walk in the spirit go to romans 8.
7 47 time flies so quickly
yes you know god is is you can enjoy the
bible you when you truly convert it you enjoy
the bible you enjoy god you enjoy the thought of
going to heaven when you're truly converted the
things of heaven appeal to you what book did i say
romans what chapter eight let's read from verse
one let me pray dear god in heaven as i speak to
your beloved people you speak through me in the
name of jesus christ i appeal to you amen there
is therefore now no condemnation to them which
are in christ jesus read with me now who walk not
after the flesh finishing it but after the spirit
that's how we're to live that's what the word
walk means now go to galatians 5 let's read verse
25 again if we live in the spirit let us also
walk in the spirit the bible tells us that to
be identified as a child of god we must walk in
the spirit let's go and read exactly where paul
tells us that romans 8 verse 14. and i hope you
don't mind i'm sending you all to the books of the
bible it's it's good practice for you all right
thank you sister for that confirmation romans
chapter 8 verse 14. are you there all right some
of you still laboring to find it romans 8 verse 14
do you have it now read with me what does this
say if manias are led by the the other yes
what do you understand by for as many
as are led by the spirit of god they
are directed by the spirit of god and
how does god speak to us through this
what have we said and god said well let me
ask you this before you go back to genesis 1.
the bible says in first corinthians 10 31 you know
it don't turn whether therefore he eat come on
or drink come on or whatsoever he do stop
stop stop explain to me what whatsoever is
anything does it mean work why do you hesitate
yes does it mean going to the supermarket
does it mean relations between husband and wife
yes does it mean your performance in school
yes does it mean on the playground yes the bible
says what's does it mean going to restaurant
yes whatsoever you do now you finish the
verse do all that is spiritual living
now let me ask you this what
secular things are done in heaven
the farming
what secular things are done if
it is done for the glory of god
in a very real sense that makes it spiritual
you answered me correctly but you're not with me
okay all right okay listen to me carefully we must
change the way we think the world has affected us
too much the bible says whether therefore ye eat
or drink which means there's a way
to eat to the glory of god yes or no
so the next time you go to taco bell or wendy's
wherever you go you must do so how to the glory
ah that's an honest man can
you really the answer is yes
if you go to a place that says pork chops and
ribs then we have another story but you go to
some place where they serve what is uh authorized
by scripture you must eat to the glory of god
whether therefore he eat or drink do
we dress to the glory of god we should
now someone is saying this man is
extreme it's not me i didn't write it
do all to the glory of god now let's go back to
genesis 1 26 no need to turn let's say it with me
and god said let us make man in our image
patriarchs and prophets page 45 paragraph two
ella white writes man was to bear god's image
both in outward resemblance and in character
which means when god made adam adam look like god
so there's a place for the outward resemblance
adam look like god because god has a shape
you're looking at me i need medication god has
a shape are you with me go to uh john chapter
five let me let the bible tell you that you keep
looking at me with such doubt on your face as i
by the way let me thank the
sister who sent some rice for me
may the lord bless you if i could make rice like
that i'd make it every day okay john 5 verse 37.
that rice was so good i think i ran out so this
is just a hint okay john 5 37 do you have it
do you have it take rise out of your head okay
john 5 37 okay what does that say and the father
himself come on which have sent me hath
born witness of me now read carefully ye
have what neither heard his voice at any time
nor seen his shape what is jesus saying god
has a shame even though he is a spirit now we
don't understand that because all we understand
is this and there's nothing wrong with that we're
limited jesus said you have never seen his shape
ella white was taken by christ in vision to heaven
and she saw a bright light on her throne she said
who is that jesus said the father she said does he
have a shape jesus said yes she said may i see him
no god has a shape now listen again to the
words of ellen white man was to bear god's image
both in outward resemblance and in
character but which one is higher character
and so the bible says let us make man in our image
we were made to live spiritual lives even though
we're three-dimensional being first and foremost
everything is designed to glorify god consequently
it makes our lives a spiritual life i was talking
somewhere and i said there's a spiritual way to
play a basketball game some young man just
couldn't understand that there's a spiritual
way to play because whether therefore you eat
or drink or play do all to the glory of god
you're looking at me as a vacant look in your
eyes because this sounds extreme we must try
to think like god not like the world here's how
the world functions many of us do the same thing
you have in your bedroom uh what's it called
where you keep your with a lot of drawers in it
a dresser thank you and it has separate
drawers am i right you pull out this
your handkerchief you close it you pull out
that your stockings you close it you pull
out that your shirts you're closing that's
how we function you go to church on sabbath
you pull out the sabbath draw are you with me
the moment that sun sets or we push it down
what do we do with that drawer we shut it then we
open the secular draw that's for saturday night
we open the secular draw but every draw in
that dresser should be spiritual as i told
you yesterday when the sun sets on saturday
it does not set on your personal holiness
and god said let us make man in our image the
wisest man whoever lives said let us hear the
conclusion of the whole matter fear god and keep
his commandments for this is the whole duty of man
a spiritual law what did paul tell us if we live
by the spirit let us also walk in the spirit
and when we're born again
we go from flesh to spirit
and it's done by the spirit john 3 8
the wind bloweth where it listeth and
i'll heareth the sound thereof but can't not
tell whence it cometh or whether it goes so is
everyone that is born of the spirit the active
agent in conversion is the spirit of god
and he takes us from flesh to spirit let me
place this upon your mind for your consideration
in order to enter heaven we have
to be born again which means what
which means start start all over again you
can't pick it up in the middle of your life
conversion means start all over again so
you come into this world a different species
ah you didn't get what i said you see chickens
give birth to chicken or the eggs chicken chicks
dogs puppies cats kittens god created spiritual
beings because of sin we have another father well
some people do those of us who accept christ
our father's god john 8 44 year of your father
the devil that's what jesus said judas was called
the son of perdition jesus himself called him that
in john 17 12 the son of perdition which
is the same name given to the antichrist in
second thessalonians 2 3. the bible calls cain
a child of the evil one first john 3 verse 12.
as a child of god then we must be
spiritual but you just can't think about that
every sabbath it must be the way we think
all the time then it affects what you watch
on television it affects what you read
it affects who you hang out with
because i am a spiritual being you have
three dimensional hands you just have to
eat and dress and take a shower but i am first
and foremost made to reflect the image of god
and we're reminded by that every day by god
we ignore it but god reminds us here's how
god reminds us let me pray again father as i come
to the downslope please god give me something new
something enlightening for your glory not
mine in jesus name i pray amen go to psalm 19.
it's one minute eight i'll
let you out before 8 15.
i'm glad no one said amen john what book
did i say psalm 19 you know this verse
i should have told you just say it but
anyway let's read verse one are you there
read with me the heavens declare the glory of
god and the firmament with his handiwork now stop
the heavens declare the glo what is the glory
of god the character of god when moses said i
beseech they show me thy glory exodus 32 verse
18. god said in verse 20 you cannot see my face
so whatever god showed him was
not his face it was his glory
in chapter 24 verse six to eight all right five
to seven the glory of god is this character
god's amazing grace paid three twenty two
paragraph 2 god's glory is his character now
listen to psalm 19 1 the heavens declare the glory
of god what does that mean if you look up into the
heavens during the night when it's a clear night
and you look honestly what should you conclude
god is good god is good what else especially
you look night after night you see the same
patterns what do you learn about
god god is orderly god is faithful
god is consistent god operates by law you look
because you see these things the same place
the heavens declare there you go all right
go to isaiah 6. quickly quickly quickly
who has it nobody is six you
have it now all right verse three
then i want you to tell me what i want you to get
isaiah 6 3 when you found that to amen read with
me and one cried unto the other and said holy
holy holy is the lord of hosts finish the verse
the whole earth is full of his glory stop what
did we find out in psalm 19 1. come on come on
the heavens declare the glory of god how much of
the heavens all of it now what does isaiah 6 3 say
how much of the earth the whole earth come on
is full of his glory what is the glory of god
chiefly his character now which means
whether you look down or you look up
and you're honest you'll be reminded you may not
know the name god but you'll know there is a power
that runs this universe god's creation
is designed one of his purposes
is to keep god on the mind 24 hours a day
sixty minutes an hour sixty seconds a minute
because all the devil needs is for us to
slip up for a moment the devil can wait 50
years for the right moment you're looking at
me do you understand what i'm trying to say
you lower your guard and in that faithful moment
the devil tempts you you lose it catastrophe
and so wherever we turn we're reminded spiritual
being the glory of god the glory of god every tree
every bird every blade of grass every flower every
vision of the sky the seas the air blowing upon us
the glory of god it was designed for his glory
and you and i at a higher level because nature
does not have a moral character to develop are
you with me so here is nature but here is man
here is the book of nature here's
the bible what's our subject
what's god's standard for you hi his righteousness
i'll give you three verses just listen let this
mind be in you which was also in christ jesus
the same mind that's philippians 2 5. hebrews
12 10 that we might be partakers of his holiness
first peter 1 verse 15 be holy for i am holy
15-16 we have in second peter chapter 1 verse
4 we might be partakers of the divine nature we
must partake of the nature the holiness the mind
we are first and foremost called to live
spiritual lives to do that you must be born again
and the new birth changes your mind listen to
this quotation and i'll close christ object
lessons page 97 paragraph three what did i say
page 97 paragraph three the man who attempts
to keep the commandments of god from a sense of
obligation merely because he's required to do so
will never enter into the joy of obedience
he does not obey when the requirements of god
are considered a burden because they cut across
human inclination we may know that the life is not
a christian life true obedience is the outworking
of a principle within it springs from the love
of righteousness the love of the law of god you
must love righteousness that's a spiritual being
we love god's law because it expresses
his character we called upon to reflect
my brothers and sisters higher than the highest uh
that's education page 18 paragraph four i believe
higher than the highest human thought can reach
is god's ideal for his children who can finish it
godliness come on god-likeness
is the goal to be reached
how can anyone be offended when
god says i want you to be like me
there are people who say i want you to be
like me i am the head of a gang in a city
i want you to be a lot of little boys want to be
like them not little boys want to be like whomever
russell westbrook or whomever god
god says i want you to be like me
and i'll give you the power to do it where
if you are listening to me as i close
god wants you to be like him that
was the original design he has not
changed that plan that desire that standard he
wants us to be like him now in everything we
do because we're first and foremost called to a
spiritual standard despite our physical makeup
how many of you will say lord create me a clean
heart and renew right spirit within me can i
see your hand i see your hands at the other church
families god bless you hands down father in heaven
spiritual things are spiritually discerned
which means you must grant us your spirit to
understand what it means to live a life that
pleases you to understand what your son meant when
he said that which is born of the flesh is flesh
and that which is born of the spirit is spirit
your desire firstly god is to live in the spirit
paul says there is therefore now no condemnation
to them which are in christ jesus who walk not
after the flesh but after the spirit father
the whole duty of life is the law and that is
spiritual in the name of jesus christ their god
do for us what david requested in psalm
51 10 creating me a clean heart oh god
and renew a right spirit within me do that now for
us dear god as we recommit our lives to you live
in us de god live through us i pray and let our
lives bring others to christ bless everyone who
listened bring us back to mother they god to hear
your sweet word again we pray in jesus name amen